[Musique]
non la présidente du département
nassimah dindar s'est rendu dans le
quartier de bellevue à saint cloud a
visité l'exploitation de vanille bio de
jean-edouard saint-lambert agriculteurs
depuis
1994 mon exploitation à la base des
j'avais monté à se rasseoir pour faire
un élevage de boeuf
mâles charolais
né ici de se garder né ici
élevé ici abati ici consommé ici des
raisons
sanitaires on a arrêté cette
expression
et on s'est retourné le v1 mariculture
dieu est dieu c'est-à-dire la nasse
letchis hong kong ou dubaï et la vallée
de la vanille bio cultivés sous des
serres photovoltaïques une première sur
le territoire réunionnais l'idée étant
de protéger les terres agricoles tout en
associant les énergies renouvelables
abandonner mon père voulait monter
l'histoire que voltaïque à la réunion et
étant nous mêmes à la base agriculteurs
on a cherché une combinaison de moyens
pour pouvoir projet l'électricité et en
même temps pouvoir garder le caractère
agricole de la terre et cela plante qui
se prêtait le plus à ce type de culture
était bien entendu la vanille leur façon
de faire a été de préserver la plante au
maximum c'est à dire deux frères aînés
des vitraux plan de les acclimater
environnements nécessaires et de les
mettre sous les panneaux ce
eux ça a commencé à pleurer à peu près 4
5 mois ça nous a fallu
en que trois et quatre ans de plus entre
la phase où j'ai planté en terre ou la
vanille a commencé à forer non plus la
phase de thann a duré cinquante
l'acclimatation et là la production corp
une belle initiative qui contribue au
développement des énergies propres et à
l'indépendance énergétique de la réunion
[Musique]